COYOTES MAINSTAY AND FOR
BEAGLE, BEAGLE NOT IN THE LINEUP
BECAUSE HE IS INJURED BUT
SSON.
THE EX-COYOTES PASSING IT UP THT
BACK IN FROMHORT THE WHISTLE ANT
IT.
THAT PASS, TO CLAYTON KELLER AS
MOTTE WATCHES HIM,CKETS ONLINE
THE RIGHT POINT, A PASS THIS
TIME
TAKING CONTROL NOW NOW: AND THAA
RECURRING THEME.
>> John G.: YES. WITH LYUBUSHKIG
CHASE BUT COLLIDED WITH
CENTERING PASS AND IT IS A SHOT
BY EKMAN-LARSSON, MISSI DRAWINGD
AGAINST ARIZONA.
>> John G.: WELL, HE WAS THE GUY
WHWH THE FIRST
UNIT POWER PLAY AND HE HAS GOT
THE TOP
THAN AT THE SIDE ON POWER PLAY,
NOT A BIG ONE-TIMER BUT HE GETS
THOSEE
AND HE SCORES! GUYS WHO
KNOW THAT THE GOALTENDER IS A
POWER-PLAY GOAL BY BO HORVAT NOW
WITH 400
THE STAR AND THATCHER DEMKO, THE
ORIGINAL SAVE BUT THISCONTACT T.
S
NOT IN A
LINE ASAND FOR BOYD, HE
HAD AN ASSIST ON THE ARIZONA
THO
THE BACKHAND AFTER BOESER
FLIPPED THAT ONE INTO SPACE
MOTTE PLAYING IN PASS,
A QUICK MILLER, THROUGH CENTRE D
COYOTES HAVE JUST
COME OFF OF THE BENCH AND,IN THW
BACK INTO A THREE-GOAL LEAD BUT
NOW TURN THAT P
CHECKED NOW BYE THE REFEREE IN W
THAT TIME ON MOVING DOWN THE PUK
RETRIEVAL HERE FOR THE VANCOUVER
CANUCKS AND WHO COMES UP WIT